this is literally the worst weight loss advice
I have ever [Music] seen hey everyone I'm Abbey
Sharp welcome to Abbey's Kitchen. Today I'm pulling
up popular weight loss tips that I've seen online
and I'm going to tell you exactly what I think.
The Good the Bad and the Ugly. Okay so there's
not a whole lot of good but we'll get to that.
Quick thank you to Eric Williamson from Unlocked
Fitness and Nutrition who assisted in some of
the research support on this. I'm going to be
leaving a link to his team below if you want to
ignore all the weight loss advice online and get
the help you actually need. Also a thank you to
my kids for getting me sick. Popping in here to
talk skincare for a second because as a 35 almost
36 year old skincare has basically become my favorite
hobby or at least the only hobby I manage to make
time for in my day. I am always on the lookout for
science backed products that actually work cause
I got really sensitive skin and it doesn't always
play nice with every expensive cream on the shelf.
But Proven skincare is really unique. They're the
world's most personalized skincare line that uses
the world's largest skincare database. The skin
genome quiz, and the way it works is you do their
three minute skin genome quiz that analyzes 47
specific factors. So my skin concerns, lifestyle,
humidity, water hardness, UV, etc. and then proven
award winning a die selects the best ingredients
for your skin. The custom skincare kit consists
of a custom cleanser, custom day moisturizer with
SPF, and the custom night cream. it's literally a
unique formula made for you based on your needs
and once you've taken the quiz you can either
sign up for a subscription or a one-time purchase.
And honestly I'm kind of shocked. Rarely do I like
a product the first time I try it. I don't know
usually I'm kind of like a stick with what I know
kind of gal but I was thoroughly impressed with
the quality the text texture and most importantly
how well it's worked for my skin. Normally my skin
is super dry and irritated this time of year but
it actually feels a lot more soft and hydrated
and my makeup is sitting a lot nicer. So if you
want to try Proven yourself click the link in my
description box and use my promo code ABBEYSHARP
to get your first personalized Proven system
for $99 for limited time. This is actually a 50%
discount off of the retail price so definitely get
on it today. All right let's dive in super quickly
before one of you falls victim to the very stupid
scary and downright dangerous advice. Apologies in
advance if I'm extra sassy today. "You're stupid
if you're fat this is because it's so easy to
lose weight eating any type of nuts most people
would be surprised that nuts have a lot of fats
and calories in them they're not a healthy food
that you might think so stop eating them." Oh Troy
Troy Troy what am I going to do with you? First
of all one's body weight doesn't infer anything
about their intelligence, I don't know that shaming
isn't a cute look. Second they should be no shame
in buying yourself a bigger sized tank when it's
getting a little bit tight, just saying. And third,
the fat free diet plan is so '90s it hurts. This
is a really good example of why we cannot just
define food by its calories. Because unlike the
150 calories in let's say a chocolate bar the
150 calories in an ounce of nuts are defined by
their hunger crushing compounds and are super
satiating which is really key for diet maintenance.
And research consistently suggests that nut
consumption is not actually linked to weight gain. In
fact research suggests that those who consumed two
or more portions of nuts per week had 31% lower
risk of weight gain. And even in studies when nuts
were added to the diet and total calories were
not controlled, nut consumption still didn't lead
to weight gain. I talked about this in my video on
why a calorie doesn't equal a calorie but Whole
Foods like nuts are high in fiber which are fuel
for our good gut bacteria so even if there's let's
say 100 50 calories in nuts per ounce on paper
you're likely absorbing fewer than that because
your gut bacteria are just like gobbling up the
difference definitely watch that whole video for
the full scoop because it is super fascinating
but bottom line nuts are a great source of hunger
crushing compounds your gut bacteria love them too
and they can be a satiating and satisfying part of
a weight loss diet next one of the easiest ways
you can lose weight with just changing one thing
about your diet this is Guy a look at all the
water in his belly now look at guy B and look
at all the water in his belly and over time what
that helps with is puts you in a caloric deficit
so one of my top tips for all my clients is to
grab a half gallon jug and if you're trying to
diet instead of grabbing food take a sip of water
okay so this advice has some Merit but when it's
presented like this it can definitely do more
harm than good so yes research suggests that
staying hydrated can potentially support weight
loss through a few different important mechanisms
one via thermogenesis where drinking water
particularly cold water can transiently increase
energy expenditure by around 25% amounting to
an extra 23 calories burned per day is that
going to move the needle probably not a whole lot
but I guess all these little thermogenesis boosts
can help two as he's alluding to here water can
help to stretch the vagus nerve and transiently
reduce appetite and chloric consumption one stud
he found that having two glasses of water right
before a meal reduced chloric consumption by 22%
another study found that overweight and obese
folks who drank water before a meal lost 44% more
weight but these are all short-term intervention
studies where calories are carefully manipulated
and because the appetite suppression is temporary
and limited by the short Transit time of water
in your stomach they don't actually tell us a
whole lot about what happens when our body kind of
figures out that it's trying to be hacked so when
we look at long-term observational data we see
that those who drink the most water consumed 9%
fewer calories and that greater water intake is
associated with lower risk of wak ging but it's
largely hypothesize that most of this benefit
is not because of the thermogenesis or because
of filling your belly up with water it's because
we're replacing sugar sweetened beverages with
calorie-free water it's also important to knowe
that there is a physiological difference between
hunger and thirst Sensations and it's through
hacks like this that we may actually further dull
our ability to tell the difference difference
one study found that Freel living individuals
respond incorrectly to hunger and thirst 62%
of the time and trying to fill up your belly
with water whenever your body is literally
hungry for nutrition can just potentially
further this disconnect so no you shouldn't just
try to water down your legitimate hunger this is
super disordered advice and it insinuates that
any and all calories are bad even if it was not
the intention of this Creator my advice is
a lot gentler and that is to make sure you
drink adequate water throughout the day while
maintaining regular adequate meals in a modest
chloric deficit if you have a sudden bodily
discomfort come on and you are truly unsure
if you are hungry or you're thirsty have a glass
of water and wait a few minutes if the craving
for food persists you are hungry and you should
absolutely honor that hunger not just attempt
to drown it out with more water okay moving on
hey Gary what's the top concerns about weight
loss weight loss weight loss is a big topic and
it's the most misunderstood topic on the planet
today next to hydration if you want to lose or
regulate weight instead of losing weight get
to your natural weight the best way to do that
is remove the stress from your body one to two
times per day it's stress at the end of it it
doesn't matter what you eat and it's because of
the adrenaline norepinephrine and cortisol that
you're firing in stress hormones get rid of the
stress hormones do a fasal maneuver the stress
reset and the organ reset do that one to two
times per day your weight will start start to
stabilize right away I'm not really sure what
Gary's qualifications are his bio says lifestyle
artist and citizen scientist which I'm pretty sure
is just a pretentious way to say lay person
but his website sells fascia massage courses
so naturally doing these Maneuvers is apparently
the key to weight loss nope Dy so as I discussed
in more detail in my video on cortisol right here
both extreme diets and exercise training protocols
can increase cortisol and excess cortisol can
increase belly fat storage but the data suggests
that this doesn't seem to directly impair weight
loss if it does it's less because your stress body
is holding on to fat and more because elevated
cortisol makes you crave higher calorie foods
which makes staying in a calorie deficit a lot
more difficult so yes of course we want to try
to manage our stress levels for many different
reasons weight manage management just being one
of them but at the end of the day it still comes
down to creating a calorie deficit calories in
versus calories out is not perfect but when
it comes to Fat Loss it's still a hell of a
lot more reliable than fascia massage next weight
loss is 80% diet and 20% exercise you ever heard
that yeah it's [__] it's 50/50 let's say you're
somebody who's doing nothing but high-intensity
cardio exercises that style of training is going
to lead you under recovered and over stressed out
when those two things happen you are going to
have more Cravings more hunger good [__] luck
sticking to your nutrition plan it makes it
that much harder for no other reason than the
kind of exercise that you're doing this is why
it's important to Marry both of them nutrition
and exercise so I agree with some things that Eric
says and others are a little bit confused to start
there is no Universal golden number of how much
weight loss is exercise versus Diet you just need
to create a calorie deficit and you can obviously
do that in a myriad of ways all diet all exercise
different permutations and combinations of both
Etc that said I will respectfully disagree that
generically these two factors play out 50/50 and
I'm going to explain why for the vast majority
of people weight loss and particularly fat
loss mostly comes down to diet since exercise
alone is a lot more susceptible to metabolic
adaptations like appetite increases and or a
reduction in neat exercise is honestly great
for a lot of things but weight loss is not at
the top of that list as Canadian obesity doctor
Yoni friedhoff always says you can't outrun a
[Music]
fork well you can but it' be really hard as you
can see from this meta analysis the contribution
of diet alone to weight loss is significantly
greater than exercise alone although obviously
a diet plus exercise regimen offers a Competitive
Edge as for hit training and cortisol research has
shown that intense exercise for an hour and
15 minutes or more results in a significant
increase in our cortisol levels which makes
total physiological sense cortisol's job is
to break down fat to make it available to muscle
when you need that energy so high cortisol levels
during or after a workout is not necessarily
a bad thing it's actually a sign of a really
intense workout session in fact cortisol has
a stronger association with muscle gain after
strength workouts than testosterone or growth
hormone and when cortisol is given like a drug
it actually can improve exercise performance and
while there definitely are some cases where overe
exercising can cause daily levels of cortisol
to climb it's generally still more likely to
reduce cortisol levels over the course of the
day which actually means fewer food cravings
even during the most intense training periods
of of sprinters their daily cortisol levels are
lower on average than those who do not exercise
now the exception here is when you combine over
exercising with severe chloric restriction this
is where we do see a risk of elevated cortisol
which may impair fat loss among other health
concerns hence why I advocate for fueling your
body adequately when and if you do exercise
bottom line I agree that exercise and diet
do have to complement one another in that if you
exercise more intensely you need to eat more and
if you are not exercising much you need to eat
a little less but for the average individual it
usually does not contribute 50/50 in terms of
importance for weight loss next do you want to
lose weight fast so we doing a 7 Day liquid Fest
so the first thing that you can have is protein
shakes you can have no more than six protein
shakes within a day most of us will only have
three or four then you can have broth the next
thing you can have is your tea and your coffee
oh and I'm going to make sure I got my apple cider
vinegar shot in and not to mention get your water
in stay hydrated so Kesha let me quickly just
get this straight here you're suggesting that
we go for a week where the only thing you're
going to consume with any kind of tangible
amount of calories is protein shakes and most
of us will only get to have three or four so if
that's the case you're suggesting we have between
500 and 700 calories Max with zero carbs and zero
fat for a whole weak and to add insult to injury
you're going to drink black coffee as a standin
for energy broth with nothing else in it and apple
cider vinegar which will most certainly exacerbate
any nausea you're feeling from starvation I mean
yeah if you can maintain that level of torture for
seven days you can expect to lose some weight
I mean if you're not constipated as but even a
pure protein diet will not save you from muscle
wasting on a starvation diet like this this not
to mention when you inevitably binge on day eight
you will gain the weight back but more likely than
not in fact as I discussed in my video on Macros
for weight loss we know that going from 10 to 15%
of calories from protein to 20 to 30% or around
1.8 G per kilogram can significantly increase
fat loss by about three times I think a daily
protein shake is a really easy and effective
way to meet your protein needs especially when
trying to lose we weight but if you're going to
drag yourself through 21 to 42 protein shakes in a
week you're going to burn out you're going to get
the ick and then you potentially lost a really
effective tool for meeting your protein needs
for weight loss or weight management or really
anything else a shake a day is great alongside
other whole food sources of protein alongside
other macronutrients and fiber and probably at
least three times more calories all right that
was a doozy and you guys know there's so much
more to this if you like this video definitely
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment below
if you have any weight loss tips that you found
online that you would like me to unpack there is
a lot of them that I've come across subscribe to
the channel don't forget to hit up my description
for my free Hunger crushing combo ebook and
I will see you next time on abbey's kitchen
[Music] bye